[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight happy friday what a week it was
the president
accepted his party's nomination last
night from the white house
he gave a long speech it was more than
70 minutes compare that to joe biden's
24-minute zoom call last week
and the president's address wasn't
loaded with applause lines it wasn't
written in sound bites for twitter it
was pretty meaty
he spoke at length about trade and
manufacturing and jobs
he learned about illegal immigration and
the burden of more refugees from
dangerous countries
he pointed to joe biden's record which
is thin as a corrupt and incompetent
political lifer
a man who after 50 years can't point to
a single significant policy achievement
but the best part of this speech the
moment that defined it really came early
on
when trump affirmed which you already
know this is not
a wicked nation our cops are not
inherently racist
neither is america they tell you that
constantly
but they are lying the united states has
flaws
but it's also the president reminded us
last night the most
free just and exceptional nation on
earth
that's true in our country free speech
is allowed
violence is not allowed what separates
american democracy from
taliban theocracy for example is that in
america people can disagree with one
another and disagree with the government
without fearing for their lives this
used to be obvious it was the foundation
of our civic life
and yet all of a sudden joe biden could
never say this out loud
his voters have destroyed cities across
the country and murdered dozens of
americans he must stay silent about that
but donald trump doesn't have to and so
he said it and as a result for the first
time since the wuhan chronovirus arrived
here
the president seemed likely to win
reelection
democrats are watching carefully they
know this they can smell something has
changed they know why
normal people hate the violence they
have unleashed
and that's why this week finally after
months joe biden issued a tepid
statement gently scolding the rioters
but it's too late for that this has gone
on for too long joe biden's voters no
longer listen to him last night as the
president spoke a group of biden voters
gathered outside the white house to
threaten and intimidate anyone
who dared support donald trump they
waited to ambush attendees as they came
out of the convention
the mayor of washington an incompetent
hack called muriel bowser
made all of this possible bowser has
been on the mob side since the very
first day
she allowed the mob to harass and
terrify elderly taxpayers
as they walked on city streets they pay
for watch this
[Music]
[Applause]
the cops didn't protect these people
muriel bowser won't let them protect
these people
she won't let them do their jobs law
enforcement in washington dc as in so
many places controlled by the democratic
party
has become completely politicized just
as it is in the third world
if you don't vote the right way if you
don't vote for them you don't get police
protection the mob is allowed to hurt
you
last night things fell apart so quickly
outside the white house
that the secret service told kentucky
senator rand paul and his wife kelly
and two of their friends to get on a bus
and leave the immediate area
the center then plans to get an uber
back to his hotel
but the streets were blocked and no one
would let them through that's when rand
paul was attacked along with the
officers protecting him watch
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
these people are not only violent
they're incredibly stupid
they're mouth breathers they're morons
they had nothing
say her name they shouted at rand paul
they were talking about brianna taylor a
kentucky woman who was killed in a
no-knock police raid
when the police came under fire in fact
as it happens
rand paul himself authored a bill to end
no knock police raids and that bill was
literally called the
justice for brianna taylor act huh
irony of ironies but it didn't matter
paul's had to face political violence
before
in 2017 he was nearly murdered by a
bernie sanders
supporter that he was attacked by his
neighbor apparently for political
reasons and had to have part of his lung
removed
it took months to get better we'll talk
to rand paul in a minute about what
happened last night but he was not the
only one attacked
a van carrying fox news staff just
technical people mostly doing their jobs
non-political people
was blocked and boarded in the middle of
a city street
watch
we want to be clear we don't think the
van was targeted because fox news
employees were inside it seems like the
biden voters were pounding on it had no
idea who was riding in it they didn't
care
their assumption seemed to be that
everyone in a motor vehicle is an agent
of white supremacy
certainly they think that if anyone in
uniform watches blm lunatics
attack a black cop in washington this
morning
this isn't happening by accident it
didn't happen five years ago
it's happening now not because police
are more brutal or more
unarmed african-american men are being
killed by the police that's not
happening
it's a total hoax it's happening because
democrats the leadership of that party
are encouraging it and have been for
quite some time
here's massachusetts congresswoman
ayanna pressley openly
calling for violence in the streets
early this month watch
hold him accountable well make the phone
call send the email
show up you know there needs to be
unrest in the streets for as long as
there's unrest in our lives
and unfortunately there's plenty to go
around
there needs to be unrest in the streets
we've been watching what
unrest in the streets looks like ayanna
presley says we need more
and so there is more presley like nancy
pelosi and barack and michelle obama and
so many other leaders in that party is a
racial arsonist
she wants americans to despise and fear
each other
she is pleased when things burn presley
has no skills she's never created
anything in her life she has built
nothing tearing things down is the only
way ayanna presley and people like
ionoprusi become powerful
and so they push hate and chaos
republicans for all their many and very
obvious faults many of which we point
out on the show
don't do this they don't do anything
like this
when was the last time a mob of trump
voters torched a wendy's
or looted a target and if you
did if you watched them do that how
would you feel about it you'd be
repulsed
do you think republican leaders would
defend trump voters if they did that do
you think they'd encourage them to do it
again
please that's a rhetorical question you
know the answer is obvious
only biden voters do this only the left
does this and they've done it for a long
time
a year ago this month for example they
gathered outside mitch mcconnell's home
where his family lives
do you even remember what this was about
watch
we're at mcconnell's house this i think
he's about to get some rest
not if the kill the children that you're
kidnapping can't get any rest
not in families or getting murdered
can't get any rest
he's in there nursing his little broken
arm he should have broke his little
raggedy wrinkled ass neck
murder turtle
murder turtle just stab the [ __ ]
in the heart
they mocked the 77 year old mcconnell
who was recovering from surgery
they said that out loud it was on tape
we probably played it at the time we
didn't take it seriously enough
the rest of us should have stopped what
we are doing that day
and demanded demanded from law
enforcement demanded from democratic
leaders
an end to the threats to the lunatic
behavior to the implied violence none of
that has any place
in a civilized country much less this
country but we didn't do that we let it
pass we ignored it over time and so the
threats continued and then the threats
became violence as they inevitably do
the question now is can we stop it